antes de começarem a ver o vídeo só
preparem se porque eu também queria
preparar antes de começar a jogar porque
hoje vai ser mesmo de buraco é pessoal
porque isso não vai ser um jogo normal
isto é o factor que é um dos princípios
do corpo você já sabe o que é mas desta
vez no hospital é nós arriscamos na
mansão e desta vez vai ser no hospital
por isso preparem se vou aqui para agora
só consegui pessoal e vamos começar a
jogar e isto deixa-me ter esta porcaria
imposta e bora lá pessoalmente o volume
no máximo também como eu tenho e vamos
buscá lo e que juntos ok nós já temos
aqui no lobby e agora supostamente eu
preciso escolher a que o hospital não
querer se separar o próximo vídeo lá e
isso o hospital caiu espero que funcione
e em transtorno está dentro
já temos cá dentro ok só de 88 texto ou
calma isto é sua música está acontecendo
agora com o seu filho eo comércio com
este barulho acabou de passar o piso na
mansão
vai faltar um bicho a porta eu sei eu
sei que esta porta voz dentro eu não
estava aqui não vai ser tranquilo
o instrumento muito medo de morrer o que
também não é esse por cima de uma coisa
ao kagame no espaço inteiro
ok bichos dentro meu porta fechar uma
porta fechar uma porta a porta é sério e
isto isto é aquelas crianças mortas está
muito bizarra sons alguma coisa causa
dessa cama esta aqui é muito suspeita o
que aconteceu
go go quem é que o lan a isto é o
crematório é isso aqui é um dos corpos
supostamente não aqui onde fazem guardam
os corpos para fazer aquelas coisas que
elas investigações milton e gente
pendurada mel coisa meu outro lado
direito não é tudo
um show português flávio meu andar às
voltas não quero apanhar alguém quer me
acabar meu pessoal como é costume jato
tudo incluído cheiro de suor frio já
seriam só com os hits que fazem isto é
alguém que se uma porta abre uma porta
meu machado abre a porta a uma cadeira
de rodas mil por cada cadeira de rodas
michels favor lado do bota muito isto
borra muita cueca boca muito pessoal da
série eu tô mesmo em estado quase quase
de tirar os jogos rift e chorar própria
da minha mãe porque isso mexe muito medo
elas não existem porque preciso reclamar
porque instrumento muito medo que um
gato morto meu cabeça não vou estar aí
isto dá uma aflição do caraças
isto dá uma aflição do caraças pessoal
sério falar que um salto para cima tem
que voltar atrás né
é isso aqui pessoal tem que ver que
alguma coisa que nós quem já pouco atrás
do pelotão no sítio certo lá dentro
qualquer barulho nem nada
o barulho é só barulho eu sou
calma dark calma devagar devagar demais
cães que passarem stocklos é isso que é
luz a luz do meu bebê atitude eu já fui
mostrar o caminho
não sei se eu vou eu confio no canto ou
não não não
o rex pires no hospital e você já tomou
para que eu ficar sem voz porque estes
jogos de som e voz porque meu susto
ontem uma porca não é mas é isto ao
deixou a porta por lá e que favorito
fiquem vai até a próxima